what's up full podcast brought you by
our teens comedy every week what's up
fool
welcome to the well full podcast Rodrigo
Torres right here
good evening ladies and gentlemen lease
expires are over here there big old
scarf what up fool man
came back from with Palm Beach selected
my Thunder rain the people out there man
driving around La with expired tags
shitty ass tires broken windshield
car with messed up brakes take pretty
much menu checking on the world Mac will
you have no insurance having at that
house you got to make it happen dude one
way or another you can be cutting it off
nobody ever knows sure they're gonna
keep going gone with the wind so of
course like you realize that the people
who have bad cars this is like the test
right there this this rain a lot broken
down so super rules
she chose a donut on that [ __ ] dude
against all odds dog still doing it
what's up fool last week we're in West
Palm Beach thank you everybody who
showed up we had a lot of people on us
but Friday I don't know first show
Saturday right a lot of people Saturday
sold out about 10 people left to sell it
out yeah it look good happy birthday to
Rodrigo Torres everybody thank you we
sent every birthday here I forgot the
card at the club about two little cakes
yes I was staring at the card on the
table Texas wigs look mega man's here
what's up man what's up on the bay have
resin done team highest but I'm also
this boy what's so cool is Violetta make
it happen you know what lesser what's
our fool
San Diego San Diego new year new me that
what to my purse I think this is my I
went to acting class today getting
better bro what you guys doing
every we can meet her we up she gave me
some lines and then we break down the
script on in the class and there now
we're up we read a beat by beat and then
we put the whole thing together and into
there I kind of like got it bro and it's
gonna be less than an hour
I read you the beans are renewing
everything they took me a while back I
wasn't paying attention but next
audition I get brought ready bro hey
people think acting just talking yeah Oh
Stephen fly this before when I'm barely
gonna start taking my acting class back
in nineteen no back in 2003
eight maybe right I don't think so
unless you did rip when I didn't know
not what Depp you started when uh when
you knew me yeah but you were kind of
half-ass I'm going it Oh half pass him
bro man we were like what the acting
class bro cracked out raw I was hungover
yeah and then like I would I was like
with no sleep bro I mean no one read and
then I know the tabloids when I had the
hemorrhoids bro I still got dope in her
house and she had little ass house bro
little buddies up what Disney had made a
house for his daughter soberly release
he build houses for his whole family but
and there's no white cottages yeah so
she let those feelings
this is no wife khadija they're like
dwarves like you know they're right
behind my Gelson's by Marshall High
School yeah yeah she lived her she had
one of the houses they were outlawed
feelings but there it was a tiny warm
bro like those are products you live in
the back house had a wooden door the
bathroom had a wood door bro that blew
it up bro
and I had a hemorrhoid and it heard dog
I know how and I was like not in a good
state of mind
my eyes were red
you know I gotta go finish this class
you know you're really committed to it
you're doing it every week when you're
in town you know and it's it's going
well
what did Steve I tell you Oh so I serve
other cities I think that I think you
should too that's what a bunch of people
taking acting classes he goes down I
practiced a little the real key though
what you have to have to be a good actor
though or to get it is you have to be
able to put yourself in somebody else's
shoes you have to be able to empathize
with how other people feel and that not
everybody can do that
you know like imagine how when you go to
acting class together but man oh I would
never say that
of course you wouldn't say that stupid
but this character you're playing will
say that but you can find time so in
your mind if you go back you know when
you felt like this or you we're in a
situation like that how did you react
you know my acting class I think always
say like who do you have in place of
this person I can't think of anybody
right now but you were full of this
place yeah who you talking to sort of
see somebody in your past you know like
angry or the deal the devil okay I want
to pause the person what was Alfred
Roberts playing through ladies DM lately
I was last week dog
thank you do the same thing doc I think
I made you slide it to dear people to
bro successful we have to have enough
people to enough famous friends to
notice it you have to be empathetic to a
class ah there you go there you go
kulikov it's tough to ask but I was
interacting bro you will know acting bro
what taco shop so acting class that if
everybody broke the hair is like Brando
in that movie he broke that Brando bro
he's up what not to do
he did the miser technique but a man it
must be tough like you started your
whole life to want to be an actor first
and not a comedian because yeah it's a
life of disappointments bro
I didn't cuz I know I made like I would
think I remember when I first are doing
nineteen classes with her and then I
went to another acting classes they were
more expensive and I'll being taught by
people who had masters in acting
master's philosophy and all that but
they're teaching that yeah that and the
thing is the frustrating thing is you
would go to these classes where it was
you and I think you've already talked
about this but it was you and a bunch of
other hopefuls and then the teacher and
they wanted you to be there for like
three hours on a Monday night or
Wednesday night or whatever and you had
you know you were working and you had
work you had TV spots you had little
roles here in there already
yeah and these people wanted to like go
over the theories of acting and a
philosophy of acting and stuff and
you're just you want help on your script
so you want help on you know I got a
tape next week or I gotta do this next
week and these these people were not
used to I know about like and you also
had another job that is lucrative you
know doing stand-up and like they're
like they're like they're excited about
Tony Awards bro no anybody want a Tony
Shakespeare in the Park over he won the
Tony's or what those day I learned about
Tony and watching Seinfeld bro with
Kramer had - Tony yeah when you were
seat filler and then like he was just
that there but he got up with the people
with the award I went over there and he
get him with Tony to it and then you
said I'm going to tell I'm going to
Sardis he said you're taking the Tony to
Sardis the Tony's taking me they know
funny we're now now forward to go party
I get a seat filler bro but he got the
Tony he went to the after
the real actors I woke up but I had
breakfast at Liza Minnelli no and then
dude he's at the restaurant gross
already by himself and he's talking to
his people about acting and he's talking
about our about our dance of a Salesman
he's making of his own theory about this
why dog danceable salesmen and then
another producer comes in here my name
is Lou Gramm and I'm the producer of the
director of whatever of director of that
play and then I'm craving for everybody
actually he knew him Lou Lou there's a
little food company who like that too
huh there's no people excited to see you
if you hear one good beer like at least
Three comedy good story from from rapid
rote rip rip oh yeah here's you know
like reputable comedians that you know
the story in detail you could claim that
story about like this with us like you
lived it like you lived there but your
town it in the third person third person
I was a fly on the wall dog were so full
picture a free press party at the
Albuquerque New Mexico no big deal it
was no big deal broke just on the phone
was so bad as I 100 percent a self-made
millionaire I don't find you that funny
I might dislike that you don't feel
angry now don't you feel angry now
listen I don't feel angry bro first of
all you never self-made millionaire some
villagers and I watching my youtube
video right now bro there's some we're
rain right now which animate the other
million dollars yes Daddy yourself made
me don't know you watching me right now
I [ __ ] feel sorry for you in
commenting knows it's a promo guy for a
self-made millionaire I'm like burn it
was there a good nearby you shoot
yourself
he's height man get Horry back on Corey
Beck I wish I bro I said when people
yellow like my name is Felipe FBI ype
and people still run a ph IL fini IPP
Phillippe I'm the friends bro the French
did do a Chris Dorian press him bro are
you talking about brown when you getting
married bro haha bro
ah geez bro September August September
bro we're getting married Eddie at the
Chateau bro the Chateau of love bro
where are they getting married because
they took their photo in front of the
improv I've seen the ice in the pit I
said right on the picture I think it's
like like a winery now oh I didn't see
you'll be the best bad bro cuz I asked
no I don't know I asked him to keep me
posted on where it was and everything
and probably his dad that's like the
move that guys make when they don't take
the lady they're dating they take their
mom to the Oscars or whatever you know
like they take their mom instead it
wasn't like a George Clooney move or
whatever when they're when they're not
married they'll take like their mom or
their daughter like Jamie Foxx when
they're not going to end up with that
girl dancing like she's not like a
long-term significance what is that
that's horrible no no like saying when a
fools take their mom to big old Ward
shows yeah but it's it's kind of a
cop-out to choose you're not going to
take your lady dog or the chick you're
piping or whatever take your piping the
lady accordin court what would you take
him to again a workshops award oh yeah
like you know like they're the the
person you would take your right-hand
person your best friend oh yeah I think
Jamie Foxx to his daughter but I think
also memory because see if you take a
girl to the Oscars any kind of hold
right any kind of woman that not your
wife or your girlfriend it'll be a
girlfriend for the next year are no
papers yeah maybe they don't want that
that's true too they don't want it'll be
a girlfriend yeah there's a part of her
around him even though she's not nobody
she will see she will be us somebody by
the other night
it just says Castro Valley it doesn't
say a place that's like a area isn't it
Castro Valley what a place it's elope or
service it's cool it doesn't say like
where the I guess there's a website I
don't get it when you in the mail she
said yeah bro
she said yeah bro of the you would have
put in a photo she said no there's
videos on internet have you seen those
ones Erstad oh my god mad
just bake now bro I probably the new
whole crew brokers to make you sad
oh dude but there's not one of that
brother dog actually this sad little
skinny dude oh my god
which one where he proposed right then
the mall and she's like nah what the
Asian one no it's a little brother
African I saw another one man where the
guy is singing a song like R&B song and
everybody's like all together and he's
singing it and then she goes that's one
that there's like a house I know why are
they posting it I don't know cuz some
dude was there and got somebody else
yeah was it bad to talk about when you
took that person's those peoples photo
in San Francisco did we talk about that
yet Wow
we spent the body on another thing to
another yeah well we didn't talk about
it here oh my god we were we were
tripping in San Francisco should be hard
dawg and we were by the bridge [ __ ]
slow rooms
well walking slow and I just wanted so
we're rolling so um we're walking out on
the pier under the bridge you know that
was the Bay Bridge I mean the Bay Bridge
so we're under the bay bridge and then
there's this couple and then she's got
like a seven year old daughter or
something and then he's he had just
asked her to marry him and she said yes
and he asked we were the only other
people on the pier and he asked us to
take their picture and he was trying to
recall a propose of him proposing
because he had just done it and she said
yes he wanted they wanted to like
recreate it we can't see cell phones
like it's you can't we can't make
anything out on the phone and Felipe is
like just shooting randomly I don't know
what kind of pictures he ended up with
and the guy who wants to look at him
he's like oh thank you so much and he's
his hands shaking because he just
proposed you know he's all nervous and
he's flipping through the pictures and
he's like can you take it again cuz they
were all bad so I said I'll take it and
I'm looking and
everything's blurry and I couldn't make
up you know and you look at your cell
phone next to it and it's all weird
see all these words all those little
rays align see every little little inch
a little centimeter of it and oh my gosh
I couldn't see [ __ ] and I we ruin those
people's no it was like a little Latino
guy Marion of the black woman and he
would pull right in front of the
daughter yeah and it was very sweet but
I felt bad like we couldn't help we
gonna leave really fast oh my god then
we walked like an hour and a half all
over Chinatown bro then we start I will
had a heart attack bro doing this white
family and they were like and they were
walking with her mom and their mom or
grandma walking real slow right they
were all behind her and she was walking
stick to walking sticks like she was a
checker palm tracker poll boy sure we're
not believable and struggling smelly
moose piss families behind the whole
side would be higher come on grandma and
then I forgot what I said this is the
last birthday we're doing this grandma
[Laughter]
she was Carole EcoSmart ever up the hill
dude I couldn't stop laughing man don't
explorers use those sticks yeah it's
it's like trekker you know you go hiking
with it or you use it on a regular trail
or whatever
somebody please started go fund me
account for DoDEA to get a sound
technician for his shoes the most squeak
or what I think it's those old man shoes
the New Balance those don't those things
squeak fool the [ __ ] [ __ ] up hips
gotta wear those
hello spooky guy they spent four dollars
asking for a shout-out that's one more
bug though
shut up too squishy shout-out to any ice
house shows nah bro - this guy Joseph
this was the year your coke dealer
impositions buy soda bro I think they
want to hear it wrong
tune into me a free channel snapchat
Victoria Texas in the house come check
us out Joseph what else bro when you
make sure well I was gonna do a show
tonight dude but I had to cancel I'm
sorry no worries dude so good
we're SAV yes well we used to do show
the host fools sometimes to them like
the Bailey man and a man and Cisco I
haven't run into Cisco Trenton many many
yeah lie
fly tube flies been a longer time like a
year dude penny man it was like three
months ago but still doing it or just
whenever they get booked they're doing
it on the real you know the Laugh
Factory at 10:09 suddenly I haven't been
here in the last time I had a cancel cuz
then come home on a Monday but it's all
good not as much as there used to be
back in the day brother Latino man this
should be more sure than it was back
then bro there's more way to promote I'm
actively was anywhere like that that
much bro social media and people showed
up it was more personal person back then
with flyers and tickets and you hey bro
that's Gino night I used to sneak up on
people crazy dog that fourth man I were
more than a [ __ ] bro yeah did a
lot of these people came from the South
Beach yeah senator Lee spring swapmeet
house so empty buncha bro he started I
was started after his PO lately
beginning a lot of style is propanol
tired bro I seen his salad and they look
appealing bro
got those iceberg lettuce iceberg
lettuce doesn't go well people think bad
iceberg lettuce shouldn't belong with
anything that's greasy like like chicken
shouldn't be in a salad so here's my god
eggs and this place does it make salads
you could tell that that came out of the
fridge yeah premade with saran wrap over
it and they just said here you go
Airport salad a cafeteria salad yeah
gross man I've been going through some
little ass
little at airports man like a little
tiny Airport little airports have liquor
stores inside yeah like there were
snacks was that uh that was Westchester
Westchester huh
I was a dude it was like dude it was
like a cup of noodles bro it looks like
an ampm in there awful kind of like
am/pm like it was a trip dude all right
for everybody asking about new cities I
just put a flier up
I made that flyer and I knew there were
gonna be a hundred other questions of
other cities other dates are coming it
says more dates are coming this is just
what we have confirmed so far for this
year so all these other weekend's will
get filled in with dates they'll start
coming in don't worry
Chicago Oxnard San Antonio all those
places they'll come they'll come in
they'll get there I know people is
freaked out can't have rules they do
rule bro so watch them turn us off right
now I super when people yell out other
podcasts on our our feed like we're
gonna start [ __ ] with them and those are
friends you [ __ ] what oh my favorite
podcast is such as such under watching
or like we're gonna talk [ __ ] about
their podcast
they're our friends [ __ ] we are part
of the same community you piece of [ __ ]
stuff party [ __ ] where's Jorge Goodwin
is right here brought this back yes
although Viviano yes he likes heavy
metal Oh Jeff Garcia now that [ __ ] that
you like heavy metal I do a metal bro
they're just starting energy there just
aren't any new metal bands - it was a
big tummy sticks we don't even know that
game come to Grand Rapids Michigan a
I've been there ever been during a
long-ass time
well you have a feedom a perm thank you
brother work of my perms brother
hey there for the the parking lot killer
used to talk about that how you doing my
brother
I'm doing great brother like Bible talk
huh I got told you the word the Lord
so Mortimer and no bro no in my CDs bro
I even know where to play oh I
understand why I'm in my car in the
Screen Actors Guild Awards they always
send me umm see DVDs bro well they send
your DVDs oh maybe it's just great but
they sent us DVDs of the shows that are
on Netflix and Hulu ozarks they have my
tail they send me a nice little package
but I already watched it all the be
cheaper just a mere subscription to UM
Hulu for a week yeah watch it yeah that
would be smart
perfectly gift they're both human wraps
- yeah I got the DVD you seen it I got
it home I can't even think of who
doesn't have Hulu like we're thinking of
maybe a sister doesn't have it will hold
onto those discs like Hulu has some cool
ass [ __ ] on it man about prime oh yeah
you know are not watching College with
friends oh my god don't even know
poverty bro
no it's called friends from college I
found out that that little asian girl
that's uh Randall parks wife really
she's fog the one on the show yeah oh
yeah Randall on fresh off the boat right
the woman on college in real life that's
ok that's the one the other one is the
one that comes on crazy with changes
she's fine but uh yeah dude that shows
good dog and it's good dog I don't know
okay don't spoil it for me but tell me
what you want yeah friends from colleges
to show it really good
so on your truck watch the monitor hey
what is that blue out Singapore noodles
that's what it's called the pork and the
it always comes with everything we try
to get without it but it's hard to get
it without stuff it has a dry curry rub
it's the best but it's hard to get it
without the pork they'd be good to have
one car dude Wow the Singapore noodles
well yeah I ate it too fast but you're
hungry now your car I know I didn't see
the episodes to the noodles in your car
no I went to go get expressor with the
choice all the money they were quick
they were like shorter than last year
really yeah so to see my to me they
flipped it's good you know well the
first did for some reason I thought but
I'm thinking it's like that's what was
it thought when she cheated to with the
wife with keys wife yeah Ethan's wife
yeah and uh I thought she was gonna come
board they're gonna come back the next
season she was gonna be pregnant
because I thought she was pregnant by
Nick yeah because I don't think Ethan
was able to get her well he did he kind
of broke the ball he kind of didn't want
to like he was like you know getting in
the way of it
yeah and I'm in season to you real you
thirsty anymore how bad the relationship
was to be together for that though many
years cheating on her partner whoa dude
I got you the part without oh my god I
got to the part where that with that or
that girl's husband made I recall oh my
god I could see somebody doing that if
you're really hurt he did show to my
birthday sure yeah I didn't remember
we didn't remember that you know at the
end of the last season Ethan's wife
announces that she had an affair but we
didn't remember that Sam and Ethan were
exposed as well how did that happen
their affair was exposed to everybody -
that same day yeah we don't know when I
have to go back and watch that last
episode because they were talking right
because I thought it was gonna be
revealed but then he was like oh yeah
regular TV then show the big 20 episodes
yeah and Fred Savage is awesome his
partners did - I liked how his partner
like you know he's gay right but he
ought but hates his friend it's not
coming from a gay side coming from a
further losers oh yeah yeah but dude you
need to also see the homophobia - when
they dudes running out I think it's oh
yeah do you gay wedding to the best but
I think everybody's significant other
doesn't like the way they are with their
friends including Sam's husband and
anybody else yeah they're still stuck in
that little bubble and like you know
it's over now it's over that's what you
think that's what that song for Tom
Petty hurts so much man the good old
days may not return in there Tom Petty
song
learning to fly off every time like the
song is really good but then when you
get to that part about the good old days
you just think about the good old days
you have with your buddies but but
they're not gonna come back you know
what I did it's already happened you can
relive those days but they try to relive
them especially when they're moving now
in this plane 290th music Ben Folds Five
or whatever it's not playing they play
first they pull around again that's I
think that's the feeling you do get from
the show but in closing I think it's up
to you guys to make it survived I think
they do it again
no paper over here in closing summing up
in conclusion it's a good show man
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah Ben you gotta make that
[ __ ] happen Bubba young man Felipe for
white dress bro
thank you who will become supermarket
jovis Felipe okay brother that I show
supermarket yeah he hasn't been back on
this season you are my father my family
totally me brother [ __ ] you see there
the name run everything they're saying
but just to continue talking bro bro you
know you're on the show supermarket bro
with ariana grande bro
and the guy in the wheelchair but you
know what bro Google is so smarter
picking up stuff from idiots like me who
don't know [ __ ] then it finds it uh uh
recipe for blah blah blah it'll find it
that's just called fuzzy logic that's
it's artificial intelligence autocorrect
yeah it's it's learning from you based
on previous mistakes that people made to
Jesse go low who just showed out about
what is this it's how YouTube wrong
you're commenting on YouTube right now
okay together the internet asked about
our Kelly did you watch that Kelly yeah
I watch it would you watch Don Antonio
sorry man yeah I haven't seen anything
but people say that um well that's what
nobody even know is airing no I'm Toby
Hicks said there was a video of him at a
Chicago after-party and there are the
girls were standing in line take photos
I am and he showed up with like a super
hot lady did older or younger than 18
but I don't know who she's occasionally
throughout the the list of women there
are a few of age you know well some of
them are nine
but there are a few who are little older
that he meets along the way but one of
them makes a good point because she was
kind of dragged into this move to
Atlanta the Atlanta house who one of the
girlfriends and she was an older woman
she was like 30 I guess when they were
dating this was she was introduced late
like maybe the second or last episode of
the third or last episode and she she
talks about how he was he kind of was
abusive or strict you know like he can't
talk to anybody nobody the cream nobody
in the crew none of the don't nobody
come you sit there and stare the
comedian the opener forgive her yes but
you but she would talk about stuff like
that and then one day they came over and
she was about to leave and they said you
better get all your stuff because we're
leaving right now we got you you know
you got to get on the bicycle and she's
like what she was ready to leave the
house and this was in Chicago and then
they said no we're going to we're moving
to Atlanta and they moved into the house
and then they said this is your room and
this is but it basically has girls in
each room like waiting for him yes the
studio and the regular house in studio
in his house like just each room has a
girl waiting for him in his house mm-hmm
and they're not allowed to talk to
anybody they don't have any
communication some of them do but then
they get their cell phones taken away
for abuse of personís she was looking
for bangbros oh yeah I mean it's it's
weird it's weird for sure and
something's definitely weird about that
wolf story about that lady said that
could you really got paid well that
story about oh no that was a girl
commenting on Facebook just where we're
coming up yeah because a lot of people
you know we know some people from
Chicago and they will they were talking
about our killer yeah
so some well there's Brian Babylon and
all those people too and and people in
the black community who live in Chicago
like they know about all these parties
that were going on with young girls and
it was like kind of vidi ho people who
want to be videos and stuff like that
you know and so this girl commented and
she said man my
mother my my sister was always getting
invited to those parties
we were both underage I never got
invited I didn't look like my sister she
was more stacked you know and all this
stuff and she said she showed up she
said she was always invited and she
never wanted to go but I always wanted
to go and then her mom made a comment
like a few years ago man imagine if you
got if she had gone to those parties we
would have been we would have been rich
by now
and she said neither of us talked to her
might have spoke normal sense
she would have peed on you but a lot of
those girls seem like they come from my
family's like that with you know parents
are kind of dumb and you throw some
that's like the that's why it's it's
worked and also all those people along
the way they were purported anything
nobody reported to the cops that he's
[ __ ] alley in the back of tour bus
they're all 15 when they got married was
date though Nevada they got married in
Vegas they got married 1800 there yeah
and they forged a birth certificate and
they lied but her parents annulled it
that means they knew he was [ __ ] with
her when she was 15 and then she was
never to speak to him again so it was a
guitar but yeah the thing is with that
tape that got sent there's somebody that
like you know got a copy of it from you
know from that one girl they made copies
of it so somebody set him up to get
busted but the girl on the video the
parents say it's not her he says it's
not him he doesn't get convicted so
that's like the biggest case ever and if
you can't get him on that what are you
really gonna get him oh yeah and and and
it's like Corey Holcomb was talking
about you know you date a ghetto chick
you buy our case of water and she like
will do anything for you she thinks
you're the best thing in the whole world
you know you sure they don't get her
some Vipers with like a father some of
those women do to have a father and a
mother together yeah and that one woman
who's missing
and then like but she liked her to me it
also seems like she fell out of like
friendship with our Kelly or nothing
really happened with her career or
whatever she's kind of pissed she's
talking now that's how everybody's
talking yeah making fun of her album
gonna drop yeah you see them and they're
wearing like a different like outfit it
has the whole thing like they go to the
hands look you know which is who knows
what they went through who knows you
know but it's like you gotta like say
when something's wrong like that what's
happening they did another wellness
check on his house and they basically
put him in another room so they could
talk to the girls alone and they said
they were fine and they're all of age
now but the parents haven't spoken to
them in like three four years now a
little sex and later he does know those
girls way to be singers legit ready to
get [ __ ] I remember they're
brainwashed now so I think they'll do
anything he was like one was like an
aspiring singer that other yeah that's
how it starts but eventually there is no
John I remember when Elliott died all
everybody a lot of people know that like
you know every it's something that's
been known but now again like you know
it's like the Cosby thing somebody says
it on a platform or something and gets
blown out again and burn the people that
lieutenant like sad try to come on and
say but how about Woody Allen but how
about this how about that I didn't raise
the fact that are Kelly did it too Yeah
right
you depending on when they're all
Boreanaz little trouble to man he raised
his daughter
yeah I had married an MTV grocer and not
to despise that George
he got elected he's pretty much done
that judge more all right Roy Moore but
but people don't know that in
Mississippi you gotta be 14
yeah 14 yeah maybe they should go after
this pervert brought there's law Hawaii
what Colorado is 16 years old and above
I used to be younger than Point New York
is 16 or 17
yeah yeah it's and a lot of those guys
know like Jared from Subway was trying
to bring a stick to your girl from New
York to California you're breaking the
law
look at the logic like Elvis there has
to be an age in that law there has to be
a law to tell you not to do that yeah
because before they were doing it with
like knowing Marc Maron used to have no
joke about that like there we have to
have laws to tell us at different ages
what's wrong
you know having sex with dead people
dude sexual a lot of Chow is wrong both
yeah play with a cadaver like who but he
got cop piping a cadaver and I think
it's only abuse of a corpse is the only
charge that you get right the only
record I know like I have the record at
home bro proof I've been about Roma she
was killed was when she died a lot of
the more people there they say they were
they daughter would just that you think
I pregnant just recently dude that's
gross I don't think old oh girl I don't
think so
the that's a new Jesus right there might
be born that kid what was your mother
doing over there for me a child of God
it's about the woman I loved you did it
with you know went for walks the but
throughout history of entertainer junior
but throughout throughout history the
history of entertainment there for
people doing that stuff I mean you got
Roman Polanski got Woody Allen
but you had Jerry Lee Lewis who married
his 13 year old cousin Elvis who Elvis
is well I always be obsessed with the
Elvis story but but in Elvis in me in
Priscilla's book the Priscilla's book
she talks about I read that book she she
talks about she was over in Berlin I
think Germany where I spotted her with
the family right he saw her and she was
an American and he was a serviceman
always telling it in the press
just do her prayers before she was
asleep I'm gonna tell you right now I'm
gonna give this rosary the Priscilla
thia pretty one for Jesus and a one for
me you know I could you know always talk
about that I did I loved the Lisa Marie
Presley her mom would be in a room right
you mean Priscilla yeah Priscilla no her
mom they basically let her go live with
him as a guardian Oh
you sign over there Scott yeah because
alia did with Leah's parents did we all
come and see she knew that Reza
he threatened to run away he looked good
back then though she threatened to run
away she was a develop woman at that age
Doha 14 to the little girls
I don't remember just getting full of
the ho that big old hey well he made her
a dress though yeah Oh another form of
abuse your lady to dress a certain way
and with the family he already got
through the war he was a full-grown
[ __ ] man yeah how do you look at a
14-year old Rugel
Mayan she is heavenly my well because
because he has a problem he had a
problem because he had such an issue
with his mom and she was such a queen to
him such a pious woman that is fell
apart when she died when she died it was
pio us she was he was devastated when
she died
and so when he what he loved about
Priscilla was she was clean
she was untouched she was virgin he and
he had an issue with like somebody
somebody else having it before him but a
lot of meanwhile he when she when she
came to live with him he promised it
would he promised her parents that he
would take care of her he wouldn't have
her go to school he would have a
guardian all the time and his his I
think it was his baby but come back up a
long huh or something like that
was living in the house and that she
would be a chaperone and all this time
you hear some earplugs it ended up she
was just she all he did that was
parental like with he'd send her to a
room when it got late and he was having
parties late he had her on pills he had
her Dyer hair black because that's how
his mama's hair was
and she wore big old fake eyelashes and
stuff and she made her look like a woman
but and you know they were messing
around of course but he had her on pills
pills to go to sleep pills to wake up
and pills to lose weight if she if she
gained a little weight she stopped going
to school and then he he was having
affairs with an Margaret and all these
people and we showed on that one in the
hard rock that big old coat like the
lady that made made it for him she was
having a friend with him and he would
get up in the morning and send all his
girlfriends flowers yeah and she knew he
was messing around she got jealous
because she saw she would see him
flirting with these other women at these
parties but then she got sent to her
room like a kid you know that's when he
treated her like [ __ ] no no no pouting
and graceland their mama yeah she just
became she woke up she left you know she
was finally a woman should her kid
but once she had her kid then he was
like that's not my kid for a long time
he felt like something else happened
that's not my kid
you must have slept around then he's
calling her dirty this is the only
mansion but it was a dressier [ __ ]
gold mine just lucky man she doesn't
look like Priscilla Presley looks just
like her dad she only had one kid that's
it that we know of though supposedly
there's some other ones floating around
not surprising yeah nobody's caught him
in a recording - the only thing doing
sad sad baby a jailhouse robber but yeah
Elvis dude like but it's like yeah and
eventually like they cut off
communication from her parents you
didn't call them like that's just how
abusers work though that's and get the
legal right to like like a predator bro
just the way they have the money they
start giving a jerk
giving the job the family get gain
instead of with good jobs yeah yeah the
dude that um he gave the data hurts
franchise yeah and and and when she
wanted to leave him no no he said Nicole
yeah he's grown up stuff yeah you got a
deal with this yeah my eyeball is in my
hand
and he was like no you got two of them I
have bleeding and he was he was obsessed
with his whole the nudes right didn't
get this the rights signed over from his
wife current wife or knew who Ted Nugent
oh he's so gross what happened he got
his the right sent signed over you know
who else did that was Joe Piscopo and
Dee Snider we almost met him in nice
young girls a young girl who was
underage and but although I don't know
if Dee Snider I think Dee Snider waited
it out I think he knew or when should I
think can't remember exactly his story
but I think she was like 16 when I met
her she was in high school and then
eventually he waited it out and then
they got married when she was 35 with
chest hair dog Joe Piscopo did something
similar to one of the gatherings with
Dodger Stadium he's the peanut man and
one of the girls I used to work with us
she was a student put it with this guy
from this peanut guy who was a teacher
at Jefferson High or Washington hired
Carver High in south central history
teacher forever but a peanut man forever
sinned I just ate I'm open and one of
them when I was alive is do you tell me
all his didn't know he could touch it to
them they hire you you work towards a
fine job so lotta students to work there
he started me he end up marry one of his
students who oh yeah they won't tell me
and they're like dude I'll teach you we
didn't start fooling around - after high
school but also you do sorry Celine Dion
and her husband Rene
he knew he was married to her when she
was 12 and he was married to was married
and she was 12
Oh Celine Dion the terrorist
and he started like supposedly she got
in a fight with Kate Winslet she wanted
to wear the Titanic little charm when
she was a little debacle right there it
wasn't a prop I belong to Kate I don't
know if it was a profit belong to the
studio probably whoever rented to him
but she wanted to wear what she's saying
that song that's crazy they were
together and then they got married when
she was turned 18 or whatever whatever
I posted a meme I see man y'all worried
about you y'all worried about your kids
with Erik Kelly we should worry about
your little boys are shy lisa is my
older woman that was cables they don't
report it as much it's too good not that
just a man's more of a stronger person
no but also men at men get more
embarrassed though I think boys get more
embarrassed that this is happening and
honestly and this is what happened our
Kelly his sister his older sister
molested him Anna's prep the boat the
brothers say they were molested I was at
oh my god but that means that she was
arrested too yeah and she was acting out
as well but and I don't know who messed
with her but he his older sister messed
with them and for like seven years or so
it went on and you know and that doesn't
excuse anything but you know there are
there are girls who do it too and the
guys always say oh I wish my teacher had
messed with me when I was a teenager
about me melted you ugly man you're
still your sexualized too early you know
yeah early it's not like 17 or you know
like Martha Leone's brought you she was
a mother Martha Lyonnaise and she was
you know she look like Cindy from the
Brady from Cindy from from coma nothing
my daughter is touching for you wow
she's company yeah and she looks just
like her brother there's pictures like
little kid
she's a little Chrissy yeah she like
massages get massaged get busted for
batteries you a cool a teacher man like
she didn't give up she will take the
kids like when they're acting up a
little squirt a little pecan bro
chippy can park for like an hour and
then take him back to school and then
there's three schools over I had a
teacher once an Anatomy teacher
everybody knows an Anatomy is a study of
the human body
I thought this Anatomy no so I had an
Anatomy teacher in 11th grade and I was
16 17 and we were gonna do fat calipers
you know how you you pinch you pinch
some of your fat to check your body mass
index and all I so we were gonna do that
and he wanted me to wear a bathing suit
in class the next day right or two days
from whenever we were to play up a razor
Doug proposed but I got cold feet the
day before she they were so sad news and
so I didn't want to do it anymore know
what a bathing suit no I had a bathing
suit in Denver no no this is Ohio but I
didn't want to do it because we I had we
had to stand up in front of people in
front of the class and he was going to
measure our fat first of all I'm the
only one he's asked to do this
interesting and there was a guy that he
was gonna use as well like I was the
only girl he asked to do this so
economist I kind of started thinking
over thinking it in my head and I was
like you know I don't I don't feel
comfortable doing this one I don't want
to be in front of my classmates in my
bathing suit because I'm not comfortable
in my body at 16 didn't feel comfortable
I don't feel comfortable now standing in
front of a classroom my bathing suit so
so uh I felt uncomfortable and then when
I got there and I told him I wasn't
gonna do it he got pissed he got pissed
that I was saying no and then I felt
like all right there I felt like oh this
this is something that was inappropriate
you know and then he didn't have the
Gide do it he didn't do it after all at
all so it wasn't it wasn't about the the
fat measuring it was about me in a
bathing suit Gillis no-hitters bro
impersonations you know me bro they're
100% bruh it was weird no bikini then
bro he threw it he threw a temper
tantrum this is a grown man teacher
people are creeps man all shapes and
sizes and professions just right now
it's a little too hot so the they're
hiding right now they'll come back out
again dawg we there everybody's hiding
right now all these little predators
hiding them you have to go back twenty
years I get the Predators of the last 20
years dawg man what about those guys
that you're talking about that teacher
there was a teacher remember that
teacher who ran off with a student no no
it's a different guy and girl he left
his wife and yes and they were missing
and he left for her and he threw away
his whole teaching career and everything
and then they went to Tennessee or
something like that right yeah he left
his wife and kids and his whole teaching
career for the for that and then they
caught them because they were on
surveillance cameras in Walmart or
something like that
I mean how strong is the pole of [ __ ]
that that makes you want to just throw
everything away like that you you're so
blinded she wanted to read my mind
election watch of what we call election
with risk Witherspoon Reese Witherspoon
were citrus ok Roddick and it's cool
after that the actor from election from
Seinfeld the one does another play
tennis yeah me know she lost her father
the food gets caught sleeping with
his student no he's graceful Harden he
says what nasty I love little bro and
her mom fine oh my god his mom reads it
bro and then I was crying fired and he's
talking to the principal he goes her
[ __ ] so we're teachers oh so gross and
then he's like playing in a band he's
having a whole midlife crisis do that
though yeah but she wanted to read my
novel but you don't have a novel I know
but she wanted to read it w-wait ma bro
my two brothers had to be with a wife
after work break oh he get stung by a
bee in the eyebrows our bad dog
I didn't fool do that dude it's just bad
never we never was just bad just turns
out bad for everyone bro it's bad for
everybody Matthew Broderick just such it
becomes the sleaze too it's such a good
movie though cuz he hates he hates her
because she's a her because she's she's
just you get so we're there kiss ass and
a perfect student and everything
resources she willingly fooling around
that teachers oh yeah she was but how
willingly can you be when you're 17 this
is your teacher and you know you're
manipulated we don't realize you know
you don't realize what you feel like
also attention like that's what a lot of
the girls said in the art Kelly thing
it's like I'm gonna be I wanted to be a
singer and here are Kelly is giving me
the time of day he's he's paying
attention to me are Kelly he's
interested in me he believes that one
latina girl thought that was her
boyfriend yeah she and he he was married
the whole time that is and had other
girls too
sad she thought she was gonna be a
singer who one of the girls what happens
you know nothing no no he just what he
does put her in the dungeon to you what
your dad or to
we're gonna dress her up we're gonna
she's my client
she's my artists were so full podcast
shows coming up Lisa oh [ __ ]
alright let's look at the Instagram
thing my lady's teacher got busted over
here over there and on about our bro I
know a girl her dad should teach me
guitar lessons right another fifth grade
tryna learn bro taught me how to shred
but I didn't I didn't want to learn of
course his daughter she ended up getting
arrested a Roosevelt High School for
sleeping with bunch of students well as
a teacher yeah when I looked it up and I
realized her name they got me a lot oh
yeah I know her I remember you showed me
you knew that I grew up with that little
girl bro she was in the mix but you know
you know your mom was talking to
grown-ups but just a little kid that in
the conversation too but they're
listening to her she knows that what
she's saying she can hold a conversation
that aid was given a responsibilities
grow to do [ __ ] that I'm but a normal
kid wouldn't do so she was growing
wasn't surely grown those girls fast
well she was a little girl she was a
little girl but she left like that fast
yeah the old mine hold my bro and you
slept with her mom brokers at remote she
was later on 15 feel smarter than her
mom she was smart she didn't be a
[ __ ] teacher and but it was either my
dad stay well tell him we were at home
nice to bug your dad yeah bro but
pursuing my neck over the old store
women shouldn't talk let alone get women
kids yes so that girl everything that
she said nothing she said was wrong but
outspoken I'll see what she was pretty
sure bro with that mind she turned a lot
of little fools out bro oh the dad gave
guitar lesson she gave sex lessons done
dates please okay Rochester New York
this weekend January 17th and 19th at
the Carlson Turlock California January
26th Visalia California February 1st
Turlock is sold out by the way coach Roy
Clark Coachella at spotlight 29 February
2nd Birmingham Alabama
February 15th through 17th that's
somebody's birthday weekend I'm not
going to Alabama with you to celebrate
that Raleigh North Carolina
February 22nd through 24th Miami Florida
was gonna rattle off the city's no San
Angelo Texas Wichita Kansas Grand
Junction Colorado Arlington Texas
that's Dallas Charlotte North Carolina
Hermosa Beach California Albuquerque New
Mexico Lincoln California New York New
York in June June 20th to the 24th 'red
Jacksonville Florida
Lancaster California Las Vegas Nevada
Cabazon California and Pittsburgh and
there be more dates added more dates
added don't ask don't ask we got places
that we're going to and we never been to
and yeah they're new cities on here so
we're trying to break into new markets
and you can find all the ticket links at
Philly piss worldcom don't google them
you will do well third party scalpers
shout out to OG Lou the 13 bro I think
I'm his wandering 1-800 G louis xiii pre
bros made it to first take oh yeah first
take what's that first take with skip
baby Shannon Sharpe in short I think
somebody gave him a package for his
birthday and included louis xiii he
always shows picture of Hennessey in
black and miles and sometimes other
cigars but I think I think they were the
blunts they were the backwoods in the
case of the back a big shout out to the
Los Angeles Rams
they're in now they're making it to the
play of this weekend they're gonna play
the one in new they're gonna play the
Patriots no the giant egos right let's
take baby Cooper Anderson Minneapolis he
has come into Minneapolis we just don't
have a date yet but he's coming to st.
Paul sometime this year
this is not confirmed shout out to yo
I've been watching playin I'm a builder
Kelly tremendous the best hilarious you
can only watch her Thanksgiving though
get Jamar neighbors on we're trying
broke up with busy it's very he's pretty
busy tomorrow really is a busy man that
would be awesome NASCAR 55 and for the
help the people like they I do they want
to go tell Bert Kreischer to put Felipe
on don't don't Felipe to go yeah man
don't tell me to be on bro you want me
to be tell them to put me on I just go
in there a man put me on cuz I'd be like
every other comment did they do to try
to avoid their begging would be begging
bro I think the bigger car makes you
walk with a t-shirt and says I don't
want to be a podcast now or ever
didn't Fred go to a party where they on
the door it had a sign don't ask anybody
to be on your podcast at home it was
like that it was one of those parties
whereas all comics and higher-level
comics and it was like no they knew
nobody wanted to be asked it was like
scratching walls when first ola had a
party on every week there was a problem
like I know he would call him and we
called Lisa right rest all over the
other parka everyone with a problem oh
and then he had a problem cuz you want
to get rid of with hose but you know how
the thing is Fred would text me like his
house was burning with some problem and
I try to help him then I found out he's
texting for other people with this same
problem answers you're right but that's
his little that's how he works he needs
chaos in his life that he creates yeah
yeah yeah but he needs to put up with
the fires everyday or well a couple
times a week
oh yeah I tried but this and then at one
time he called you when that guy was
banging on his door yeah yeah he called
me late by what a sort of odd nearby
haze like call the cops call the
pressure calls me up and he sent me live
video a guy knocking open the door you
were in my life are you pooping your
[ __ ] boy I got friends who called me
up for you uh probably no cops from East
LA the rest are saying ah I'll never
mention your name how can you know that
was you get out of here
open the door you loser whatever anyone
Felipe the guys at my door bro call the
police balli we're gonna do
well let me call for you I don't I don't
want to pick up a case that you know
Felipe's a return call rate it's like
10% of the cost if you call a lot of
people first I'm gonna meet somebody
that actually gonna show up and that
rubble yeah especially they're like they
really think you need assistance like if
you came over there
you'd start punching and ask questions
later you know and then you're gonna get
in trouble that's crazy man bread's just
a male version of his mom she's in a
higher arm citing any Mega Man and
[ __ ] I like the large to be a
bodyguard
up there la familia spars the episode
update I was trying to get stuff to
Angel actually my box
my brother angel had a great birthday
birthday on December 19 he was off the
grid for two days but he's saying
wonderful birthday I believed him cuz
he's been away most of his birthday it's
been locked up Filipa was a twenty
dollar forever 21 bomber jacket you wish
bro I was 21 from Target dog
Goodfellow oh yeah that is a damn fool
about what what stores jackets come from
see people will know exactly what you're
wearing it's hard for the people to date
could they steal girl or she's killed
members I would [ __ ] where NASCAR from
Target but it looks good I like it
cherry who would be able to look up his
schedule now they don't look they know
how to type in Felipe's Worldcom
damn damn Auto BB on your birthday
December 18 1989 Sun woo isn't that your
son's birthday December 23rd Avenue
Felipe I was suddenly Felipe Anthony and
have a son named Philip actually his
daughter's name Philippa Philippa Philip
Jason George Foreman Felipe now she was
cool as [ __ ] there's that Felipe I
worked at Vons Philippe's just like me I
just want to do that your dad wanted a
boy huh
that's all I want
who named you your mama your dad I think
my dad because my dad had a brother
named Philippe who passed away when you
were 14
I think your mom had a brother named
Philippe yeah well she had a fabbrizio
probably CEO which is why she named it
so no I don't believe in the man his
brothers Fernando friend I noticed that
I don't know about stop adoring
community or anybody I but I know then
the Mexican community whenever someone
called dawn he's never skinny bro or
Dona is never skinned and if it's a Dona
Ana too many donors yeah this guy wants
to knowing your method is a picking up
chicks do tell Felipe as far as it Oh
what you do bro
NASCAR PT pilot first of all you don't
date but the way you go to a party bro
and you're Wagner together who's sad
Wallflower yeah bro you know you gotta
be like that guy in uhm and fly to the
Condors Conchords fly the Concorde
mirror that guys say brought our sparkle
you had a party bro you gotta be the
arsh barker bro oh yeah and you're gonna
be you're gonna be away from friends
like you're at a party
stay away from the group's no woman
looks at groups they look at guy who is
so low so you go over there bro and you
take on a [ __ ] no panic your brand
poems bro but you write notes about
yourself you know you're right because
no woman wants to walk up to a group of
guys because she knows that those that
in a group of guys they're gonna be
[ __ ] a pervert or perverts or say
something inappropriate they're gonna
team up team up yeah but if you got that
one guy oh he's sensitive
that'd be the sensitive guy alone like
arch parkour Flight of the Conchords
right he was pushing them away bro I
want to be the sad guy here so then
we're going to approach you well you
have to approach them so you gotta sit
there brother at the party bro and then
bring that a little book we'll start
sketching the party bro be interesting
bro be the gun if you want to talk to
you gotta be [ __ ] get along the
sexiest man bro get a little talent and
go you know
go somewhere where they can yeah you
know Rubby would be together breeze of
the tarot cards kills it in karaoke bro
I know but something about how was the
party Oh piglet arrow guy devil card
best about Melbourne we are trying some
international stuff but I think what
we're gonna do is wait until his new
special which we're it's an undetermined
date where we're gonna film it this year
for Netflix once that comes out that'll
be international and then we can start a
little tour after that and in Australia
will be on that list of course because
that's our biggest international podcast
audience is Australia followed by the UK
Ireland and then we got little specks
all over the place in like Saudi Arabia
and all these places where bases are
some in Germany and all that so be nice
to go to Australia tour me Rodrigo
maybe somebody I wasn't just have um a
TFT goes everywhere sure and then over
the Europe have that other guy we had
your tickles everywhere was a Jason
Jason Glen Carla to be our bodyguard for
the whole week we'll get that for
Raiders Jersey Raider hat
I don't know big ass belt that stays
Kali on it don't [ __ ] around with our
but you guys help me up people and kind
of about that are down to Winnipeg yeah
in cash over well yeah you mentioned
less than kind listen kind was such a
good show
it was based in Winnipeg we want to do
more Canada to it is a little tougher to
get into Canada because there's a small
glitch on Felipe's record that just it
doesn't prevent him from going up there
it just holds up the process it's a pain
in the ass to get in there but he's fine
their food are used to what they do the
astrology on Chancellor T for his name
with Walter Mercado and he just passed
away who I believe Cuban right I thought
he was Porto Rican I don't know what it
is he was known
man also mad shoutout to Greg Riley
always done posting up shut what's up
homeboy
so that would do comedy whoo Greg Riley
white boy I understand Diego either fan
what's up ooh sergeant-at-arms
yeah he's Puerto Rican god damn he was
86 cool bro
Walter mental and that's that's somebody
there like you would like one Gabrielle
of astrology yeah Walter Mercado Salinas
also known by a stage name shanti ananda
swindler he was around since I was
little like he'll come out of a fog like
you remember him Liberace yeah just as
much as I remember Don Francisco office
you see Burke crash on his tour no I
think that I just seen this little in
the video has some of the Calgary when
you're crossing a border I don't know
bro I guess Kerry bro like like hey soos
tray hos photos he was honest I love the
tour bus with a driver and I and he was
I had to get his camera phone out on the
landscape and you can see down there
broad [ __ ] cliff bro
oh they're driving that tour bus enough
it was snow everywhere bro I now for no
[ __ ] tour business no though cakes
Brokaw wipe it apart why for the party
gone takes a little slide I want to
listen to that way for the party it
sounds like a good podcast
sounds good it's a good title it is a
great Roger white party great a great
title wife awesome party you can't beat
it
because you want to be and if you got a
brick Crashers um I watch the story all
the time man he's very involved with the
daughters you don't see a lion well you
don't you see it on Joyce people his
daughter but no birth questions they
have like dinner party for their
daughters like I just did it like dinner
party like [ __ ] up with [ __ ]
McDonald food that they have for his
[ __ ] Clemson bro
however see was that okay I feel bad you
know
you know I'm not political but but
goddamn Bruin somebody with a national
championship you don't bioW McDonald oh
they're not really this is my [ __ ]
flag football mr. president this is the
national football console whatever but
if you're reaching into your pocket to
pay for McDonald's we have limitless
[ __ ] resources well he does I mean
the government shut down right now so
they can't do that but he could hire
catering that may be a couple thousand
dollars to feed that many people what's
a couple thousand bucks for him we spent
a couple thousand on the catering for
our wedding like what do they I mean
it's not anything for him to spend that
much a little class it's American food
but it's cold
boy he busted up a straight-up Michael
Scott office because Michael Scott one
time used his money to buy everybody
sandwiches and there are bologna
sandwich would catch a bro everything
had have been cold imagine how long it
takes to get from McDonald's to the
White House late through security set it
up put everything up on the you know
mountain of burgers and then put the
fries in the presidential seal cups you
took him out of the McDonald's things
and put them in these special fry cups
only way the fries at the White House
everything is cold gross and those guys
were walking in a circle with empty
plates like what am I going to grab off
this tape goes back to Donald that's
what he did that just to get it covered
with press it looks horrible though and
I understand he's he's trying to avoid
people calling him out and saying oh you
shouldn't be you know throwing around
money during the shutdown but if it's
his money go a little bit deeper in your
pocket you know it's gonna look really
bad
just the tacky bastard that loves
attention right there but he loves that
food though he thinks that's cool this
is what they love anyway right I'm gonna
make you get more touching these guys
are in suits they got dressed up for
that to go eat [ __ ] McDonald's double
cheeseburgers at least I don't even know
quarter pounders fish fillets there's a
ton of burgers there's like five salads
no pies milkshakes right I don't know I
didn't read the whole spread I just saw
the burgers all apart and I you know
what and I went to the Clemson's
football page to see hashtag there was
no hash-table McDonald for any other
photos did they have photos of the know
me oh I don't want to post it up tamales
in pizzoli that would have been a feast
piece not have been amazing I know huh I
should make sure there's things I know
huh I know KFC that's funny how'd you
buy kids man when it when they win a
game some McDonald's yeah take my three
Pizza Pizza would have been better to
roll cold pizza and he left - he didn't
they stick around right yes I out -
chewy toe pata loca or pata sucia chewy
chewy pata loca - Ito some paisa for the
hidden a [ __ ] of a pata Bianco okay do
you know you know the Obon talk like a
redneck food it's gonna the Mexican
version bro that's alright already taco
teaching holistically to beach America
the least also problem oz midori and yes
they come here like our own peaches taco
their scheduled haven't come on command
console make on the gas or whatever he
was making oh yeah get you Lada I said I
said to Joe row because sometimes Joe
Rogan's be talking about tacos you know
that bag he get his friends back but his
friends methanol choco bro you want real
[ __ ] tacos talk to me homeboy so I
said in that video to Joe Rogan brother
bill yeah bro this guy was putting
cutting out goat meat and then like then
then like he'll put cones oh man over
the meat and they start cutting it roast
it could be nice and soft and then he
gets up to [ __ ] the meat and puts it
in a taco and then has more consumer and
now here's the kiss that the he makes
Cassidy he puts the tortilla inside the
beer Leroy he pushed the tortilla as
cheese and then he makes a
the one then he puts the two kids a year
together and then add some meat on it I
said that the Joe Rogan tremendous what
a very powerful stuff it's [ __ ]
delicious but I'm not gonna eat that you
can eat that but see what thing about
goats if you don't eat it while it's hot
you can't like if Donald Trump was
giving out beautifully a taco for those
people they would have been hard it
would have been orange the congealed you
ready to go bro let me tell you about
crunchy three pies I never liked crunchy
three-bath but one time I ate a country
three pints of yellow chick came out on
the side you know with a clean home
right bro
Oh gross it had a weird taste like a
city taste running through them totally
obvious you know and and where we're at
with palm because I told him I was vegan
and we're talking about food but
somebody asked me in front of the stage
that you always you always vegan hell
naw bro you don't know me bro when I was
about a mile
Oh bad pool you look at them he never
gets fat then one day I got fat I used
to like relate to make carne asada bro I
used to like to get my tortilla and put
in the oil and have that little tiny
piece of meat get stuck to it you know
what I mean all greasy oil tortilla and
then put the meat on it bro and then
have man ah man and or or they were
[ __ ] here after all the food was gone
bro and then like you make carne asada
you make carnitas but then the pan broke
my dad will put oil on the pan and then
start scraping everything out and you
put all that scrape on refried beans or
something brother food you put that in a
quesadilla no there's no reason whether
food not that big right that's all [ __ ]
what you say or where you come from if
you get a little something of that on
the edge of a tortilla then you take
that bite out of it when he was just in
3d talk about that never a scrape
the [ __ ] is bomb yeah your dad's
diabetes doesn't just come from sugar
it's from all that meat that's food
steak okay Eddie Bravo
you know Chicano chewy I jump out when
people like like know who say like like
Eddie Bravo wish I never only met him
one time but I've seen other pages like
like let's make him some Mexicans you
know who say all that real Mexican bro
he's Mexican there's no such thing as
real or not real
he just Mexican who grew up differently
from your from your hood bro she were
loaded Mexicans bro we grew up with a
lot of people who speak Spanish don't
speak Spanish and that's the way we grew
up bro
there's Mexicans who grew up with
Mexican who don't speak Spanish who
those more white people around them so
they grew up differently we grew up with
a lot of black people around us these
are South Central Mexicans on South Gate
they talk differently bro which is
Mexican who grew up in different parts
of America but brought Mexican god damn
it so never tell somebody they're not
real Mexican yeah yeah we're all Mexican
I was gonna say I grew up around black
people which you know black neighborhood
black school district all that did you
go white sauce you know real white girl
well I don't know all the white people
there were only a few of us in that
school but they were all I couldn't move
huh for the white flag that's true
no tickets for you guys for the white
flight no it's partially true but I
don't know that if my mom would have
left or my grandmother would have left
she was holding it down in that
neighborhood but but I went to when you
were guys were talking about three buzz
I would go to my friends houses for
Thanksgiving and they had chitlins and
but I would get there when it was but
when the moms were cleaning them and the
smell in the house I never ate I never I
never partook of the wonders of the
chitlins I never ate those first of all
Joe Rogan role cuz I knew they're in
touch they were intestines that grossed
me out first of all but they saw them in
buckets they said three busts and stuff
in buckets how's he gonna buy it
give me the bag
I don't know but it was in a giant
bucket like a tub with just this
industrial thing but their coolers are
[ __ ] different that's like [ __ ] a
district nine food right there the price
is more like a cut of the stomach right
it's not the intestines like chiller he
buzzes the straight three five yeah yeah
that's part of the stomach lining bûche
so type three passes not tripe no why
does it sound like tripe I have no idea
that's weird
but the the stomach layer girls oh
that's gross but I've never had I've
never had my noodle I never had that
part of meat cooked for taco so he'd be
medulla he had anywhere else
no just bootcamp not like menudo media
is always there it wasn't wearing it
that piece with a whole like spongy type
with the bone no no like but that's
that's tripe yeah that's tripe the
spongy stuff yeah gross
I just can't I can't first of all I
never really liked meat anyway but when
I did try it but I could not fathom
eating something that poop had passed
through and that was just too gross to
me I couldn't do it to that scrape ha ha
ha I want to see you work at that baby
knows you know bid Saul Goodman but
that's just so funny
I think that's was set out right here no
they need it everybody bro
no I know a lot of people they don't
even like my new though they're Mexican
they won't eat it you got real Mexican
then a lot of girls don't eat it what
you a good that I most of the good that
I've known they a menudo bro or that do
we wanna live like yeah man like if
you're I remember bro the best menudo I
ever had was that was at that um that
ghetto ass burgers that I'm Parkman and
sunset Tom's Tom's we have row they
still serve you up my new look
I'm a noodle to go burn a coke cup yeah
and like a 44 out there that's you yeah
good I have to order like a sideman I
should go there [ __ ] hungover bro all
cracked out eating like a man I don't
know what there's a better life oh yeah
man just eating her yeah man like coke
people I'm outside bro people think up
you get a coke but I just keep drinking
menudo out of a coke up bro after you
came out I came down yeah and I would go
there and they would make me a side of
beans and I put like a sofa let's go bro
forget about it brought in I threw up a
nine hour late I'm throwing everything
up because I'm back to getting [ __ ] up
oh yeah yeah it's like cuz cuz when I
would try to feed you when you're well
maybe I misjudged miscalculated when you
were done done but I tried to feed you
and get food in you so you try to sober
up a little bit but you were like you're
passing on everything you didn't eat for
days bro when I was cracked out in
coming down bro I remember I stayed off
stage man I said I said that I'll be
eating jacket about crying in the
backseat like Ben Affleck oh that Ben
Affleck picture was too real when I saw
Ben Affleck crying in the backseat eat
it
you need that cheeseburger all [ __ ]
three things out I'll Jack of the box
out and then you see him to our two days
later with that with that model having a
good time bro that's the way that's the
way that's the way it is bro you go from
being high I'm pretty sure he promised
her the world you're gonna be a great
actress I got scripts and then he calls
his ex-wife help me help me know what it
is like if I had an ex-wife who loved me
wasn't he cared about me and I wanted to
stop it'll be the first woman that call
yeah he knows she's the only stability
in his life and he calls her and then
she's like her face and that photo said
everything like she's done she was
totally does she's in love what she's
done she loves him as a person but she's
not she's not in love with him yeah not
anymore it's over it's been over but she
was like she was she was just like I'm
gonna do this because he's my kids dead
I remember bro like
like an animal your feet there you go
after like five days on a good one and
he'd come back and he he would like
shower I was just trying to see where he
was gonna go back out again if he was
this was just a refresh or he actually
was gonna start to try and sober up
I need a v8 and I would try to feed him
and if he said no to food and I think
you took a shower that that one night
after you came back from Peter's house
but you uh you were your feet stunk like
nothing I'd ever smelled before and they
were beyond stinks those socks though
they were like they were like soaked and
oh my god it was like a homeless person
I mean you're a homeless person I took
him off the street for after five days I
was a rescue dog squishy and then you
slept for 24 hours really and then after
your shower and then you left again and
I was like how did I leave just woke up
again you got dressed and I said where
you going what's going on
oh my go over to wherever and somewhere
downtown and I was like that was gone
man bro dude I was I will come home and
like just stinking bro like stinking dog
and they're like you would have to throw
those clothes away there's not so bad I
threw the socks away yeah
those socks bro like put away I would
take em off and I would leave a
footprint of think oh yeah we lived in
it we lived in a studio apartment and
with a bed on the floor that was a sad
apartment did you ever see that little
place man would you go I remember like
coming in from a good one like four
nights of partying a cold crack you know
and smiley bro and I'm taking a shower
and I'm rubbing my head I'm so coked out
and I still want more coke I didn't
realize I wanted more coke but when I'm
taking a screen your brains I'm gonna
taking a shower bro I am looking at the
floor and I'm looking I am I think this
crack on the floor like chunks of pieces
falling down and
pick them up it's all water innovation
well I really thought through a piece of
crack that I had lost that came that was
missing somewhere and I was looking at
the floor and I was like corroborate bro
it but it was just water but but that
was we're all ghetto boys on going off
in your head
anyways I'm sober right now so what
worse podcast thank you very much for
listening our guest didn't make it
because she had another show at the
Western theater we knew she would mind
but next week we are doing KOCO Diaz he
say he'll do it we'll see and if he
doesn't do it yet go get on him if you
want yeah get on him but Joe Diaz said
that he'll be here next week at noon and
next week and broke right le unless we
have a [ __ ] natural disaster I'm
gonna be here bro
oh man Joey's natural natural disasters
are like Trump's 56 in these things with
a big fat the old dig tour I thought
cracky was coming out of my pores bull
but I was putting always like I don't
know what what's that feeling but I
wouldn't get the I would look at the the
water coming down I'd look like little
pieces of crack and I'm trying to grab
it also at times on the 30th we're
supposed to have Esther ku as well
Esther cool yeah I think so cool in the
game was so blue 56 legged dictor
[ __ ] never see he's in the house
for good talk abou Flaco who can't block
over just to be a guest this guy if he
shows up he shows that she's terrible
sadness
everybody's got an opinion all right oh
the president just ordered how many
[ __ ] burgers McDowell's
Mac tells the back down got a McDonald's
right in the mouth but after CUDA Stuber
pocket they don't know that oh I didn't
know I was the large G their form oh
shut up to sell human love from the
human family were so homeboy everybody
everybody told that guy said human was
up that's Rory Hillman's brother shout
out to Rory he'll may who passed away
last August to August August we'll had
the best dabs in the whole wide world
and not only that Adams
he was a super super nice guy he became
a super fan he showed up to Richland
Washington with to thousands of each a
regular ceviche and vegetarian one for
me love goes water food take everybody
we're out of here